black people don't have a monopoly on
oppression they don't have a monopoly on
suffering and I think that again
framing just the black identity solely
basis of these really negative
characteristics will only way people
down hello welcome to trigonometry I'm
Frances foster I'm constantly kissing
and this is a show for you you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people our brilliant guest today is a
writer columnist and the director of the
Free Speech Union in I are following
Emma welcome to trigonometry thank you
for having me it's good to have you here
for anyone who doesn't know who you are
and we're delighted to have you on by
that we've been chatting about you for a
while your commentary on the recent
stuff that's been going on has been
fantastic tell everybody who are you how
are you where you are what has been the
journey that brings you sitting to this
chair here in this very hot room well so
I was I was born in London I'm a
daughter of Nigerian immigrants to the
UK but I was raised in a single-parent
household and my mum she worked really
really hard to send me and my sisters
kind of free paying scores then halfway
through I left and I went to a kind of
local comprehensive school and after
that went to a grammar school and so
from a really young age I've I guess
been exposed to various different
socio-economic aspects of British
society and that made me really
interested from really young in terms of
what kind of values principles and
cultures my impact and shape the way
that people perceive themselves and
their place within society so that
really started and very young in terms
of my interest in politics but now you
know through a whole range of situations
I've become a free speech campaigner I
think that that really sparked
particularly when I went to university I
think that's where I really became
radicalized I've always been really
interested in ideas but as we've seen
with this kind of free speech culture
wars and campaign campus wars I was
really surprised to see the kind of
really limiting climate in university
when it came to free speech one event in
particular I think is what really
sparked my interest and there was this
whole movement at my university in
regards to why is my curriculum white do
you call a nice a curriculum and I think
it's a really interesting move
in terms of broadening our understanding
of the kind of way in which race
relations came to be in the UK but what
I found at university it was one
particular narrative and I posed the
question of whether or not this was
useful and I received a huge huge
backlash at university and then I
started a series of kind of free speech
debates on campus and again there was so
much controversy and and kind of really
cure in relation to these free speech
conversations which I understood was
essentially the fundamental bedrock of
our democracy and how do we kind of move
forward in terms of conversations about
race and progress within society if we
weren't able to even understand that the
very foundation of our democracy and so
that's kind of where particular
university where I really became
interested in this conversation about
free speech and that's kind of brought
me onto conversation about identity
politics agency democracy and things
like that and so you also work for the
free speech Union with Toby Young why is
it that we need a free speech Union
because don't we live in a liberal
democracy can I go and say whatever I
feel without repercussion yeah I mean
it's really really astonishing how how
little I found that people genuinely
understand free speech I mean the
conversation particularly right now
about free speech is often framed in
relation to hate and smelling hate and
how it's kind of somehow in
contradiction to the pursuit of
liberation of minorities when I often
understand understood as free speech is
almost is very nature to protect
minorities you know you don't need free
speech if you aren't necessarily the
majority because you're backed up by
power and privilege it is the views of
them and minority whether that's you
know religious or ethnic or otherwise
we're kind of free speech is so
important and so for me again that's why
I kind of became really interested in it
again because I'm told because of my
identity because I'm a black woman this
that in the other that I meant to have a
particular worldview in a particular
attitude and I found that you know free
speech is actually so fundamental to
pursuing transformational change within
society and so again I felt that I had a
kind of moral obligation to be part of
reshaping and redefining the free speech
conversation in the UK and that's kind
of why am I got involved in the free
speech Union and we're recording this at
a quite interesting
to say the very least the things seemed
to be really kicking off and I thought
that the issue with free speech as you
know and you know we've talked in the
past
Disha with free speech has been there
for some time now as you talked about
you know at the university when you were
there but I am I right in thinking that
it seems too you know I don't think the
last few weeks have made a better have
they I mean it's really been astonishing
I again a the racial conversation is not
necessarily one that has interested me
from my upbringing I well why not
because we're told that all black people
are oppressed
you know you experience racism on a
daily basis and look at them of course
there's racism I've experienced racism
you know you haven't but you know look
of course there are racist people in the
world right so how is it that you know
you've managed to avoid this
conversation you know you've managed to
grow up to go through university to get
a job to be a prominent you know speaker
on these issues and a commentator in our
public society without becoming
embroiled in this in this racial way of
thinking why are you so different well
it's really interesting and you know I
started off with Mark being and I think
that that is really what has shaped me
you know despite on paper you know my
mom came to this country as an immigrant
all of these types of things we didn't
grow up necessarily rich but from such
young age I was inculcated with this
view that you know you can achieve
whatever you want you know the sky's the
limit
and I never had all of these kind of
racial hang-ups and so that never became
how I perceived myself in the world and
how you know what my potentials were
defined by and so I never thought that
you know that is necessarily the kind of
way in which that I should necessarily
engage in politics but it's become
really important now because I've been
so worried about the deeply what I would
argue is disempowering and demoralizing
message that we are sending to a whole
generation of young people they're
living in a society that has made leaps
and bounds when it comes to race
relations not just in the last 30 or 40
years but in the last ten years there
are so many schemes programs drive to
increase representation and all of a
sudden at the point where I would argue
we can actually say yes there's more to
be done but
perhaps in all the things that have
happened in the last 20 years the race
relations situation I would argue is one
of the few things that we have triumphed
and achieve and at this very moment we
are now being told that our society
couldn't be more racist more sexist the
accessible and so I find it really
dangerous this narrative that is being
told and there's many studies that have
actually kind of come out as well
they're confirming does the actual
corrosive nature of this particular
narrative so there's been you know
studies that have come out which showed
that for example black men in particular
black people are more likely to be in
high-security mental health institutions
if they have contact with mental health
services and many people think oh that's
an example of institutional racism well
actually when it's being investigated
further what we're finding is that this
narrative about the system being against
you makes people interact with that
system differently and perceive that you
know a lack of trust and a lack of kind
of cohesive relationship with that
institution which makes them more likely
to resist similar with the kind of
stigma that exists in regards to mental
health in many of these kind of ethnic
minority communities on top of that
we've seen it with regards to the
Justice ism and the prison system many
people for example are less likely to
plead guilty for crimes because they
aren't mistrusting of their lawyers and
things like that so what we're actually
finding in a lot of these situations
this particular narrative about Britain
being institutionally and structured in
a racist way is actually producing a
self-fulfilling prophecy and I think
that that's as I said a really
demoralizing message to send to young
people and that's why you know I
in some ways use myself as an example if
despite all of these things on paper you
know I've been able to achieve that and
absolutely racism exists but there's
much more to the story than what I think
is being told and why is it that we
don't challenge the narrative so you've
just put forward a reason as to why
these things exist why the stats are
where they are but why is it that we
don't challenge the narrative that is
happening right the way through social
media and so on I think there are quite
a few reasons for that I think that
there are ideological reasons in terms
of what I would argue many of the
philosophies that underpin the
worldviews that show
being our society today so those are
things like intersectionality critical
race theory so for example in physical
race theory it's frame that racism
permeates every single aspect of my life
so there's almost nothing that we can do
about it and that's very much shaping
the conversation about racism in
academia and I think that that's very
much filtering off to every other aspect
of society well on top of that there's
an entire industry now that in some ways
has a vested interest in perpetuating
this narrative and I think this is quite
a sensitive topic I definitely think it
needs to be said
you know I've spoken about you know
every hates our department having an
equality diversity and equity officer
there are many whole organizations now
that have you know solely it kind of
invested in this particular narrative
about racism existing and in a really
deep and profound way and yes it does
exist but this there's a whole kind of
structure within society that now are
embedded in perpetuating this particular
narrative if you have whole academic
fields about you know race racism in
Britain and I think that there's not
many people that feel comfortable to be
able to kind of challenge that one it's
become so embedded and permeating and in
the climate that we have but on top of
that I think there is a kind of over
correction I think that many people are
genuinely well-meaning they're hearing
black people saying that you know the
way this is the way that society is and
so obviously as we want to care about
individuals that are you know making
these claims about society it's um our
intention is obviously want to believe
that and to alleviate that but I think
that there is genuinely a problem I'm in
kind of accepting this whole narrative
wholesale so one of the things that has
really emerged recently is this whole
idea that you as a white person or you
as at this person can never really
understand me as a black woman and I
think this is an incredibly pernicious
idea I actually think that this is so
destructive because unpacks and and kind
of removes a very basis of this whole
idea of universalism and humanism that
what even though we might have different
experiences what we share is our common
humanity and we all feel alienation we
might all feel you know
Tomer but ultimately we all experience
these things and so we can put ourselves
in other people's shoes and from my
experience again it doesn't resonate
with what I've experienced some of the
most profound and interesting
conversations I've had about race have
been with people of other races and so I
think that we really have to challenge
this idea that you know someone's
subjective experience is the only valid
way of understanding the world around us
we have to defend this notion of an
objective truth we have to defend that
there are things that we can find out
and research and look at the
complexities of why that situation is
and accept that we can all understand
that as human beings and not let just
one section of society be able to define
what specific aspects mean we see this
is where I would agree with with what
you're saying in the sense that I think
that's the right way to go but I wonder
whether we've just gone too far in the
other direction that it's not possible
any longer I'll give you an example you
know up a friend of ours who watched our
interview with Aisha I can be who you
know I sent it to a friend of his and
his friend said yeah I really enjoyed it
because she was a black woman talking
about her experience but but you know
what I mean like the majority of people
have been in calc you know indoctrinated
with this idea that that is how we think
and I'll be honest with you I think you
know us we've been indoctrinated with it
as well like I haven't I'm very woke no
I wonder whether let's be honest if
Aisha was white or if you were white we
would have you as readily on our show as
we do when you're not white do you see
what I'm saying
no I do understand that and obviously
there is some validity to the notion
that you know being obviously of a
particular race and if you're having a
conversation about things that affect
that race and they're going to be more
invested in that particular conversation
but it's but it's more than that I think
there's one thing kind of listening to
other people but there's another thing
as homogenizing them all becoming a kind
of spokesperson and that's one of the
things again that I think has been quite
toxic I've seen essentially a kind of
concerted effort to create an
all-encompassing mythology about what it
means to be black in the world today but
particularly Britain and a sin
realizing that narrative to be one of
racism oppression and victimhood and the
problem with this kind of homogenous
view is then when you have ethnic
minorities you know minimizer myself
other people that don't experience or
don't feel that this particular
narrative speaks to what they've
experienced then we are then you know
framed as the other and so ultimately we
need to be able to say you know you were
speaking for yourself as an individual
and and what our individual experience
is ultimately what is important and not
be solely defined by these categories
and why do you think the debate is so
toxic because it's not just toxic when
you know people come out and talk about
their own experiences it stops it within
for instance the black community I mean
it's a ridiculous thing to say but you
know somebody like you says they're
experienced and you know then you get
other people using racist language
against you and you think why is it that
we can't have a simple honest discussion
on these matters I think that a lot of
people are really kind of so if you
create as I said this all-encompassing
narrative about what it means to be
black and you inculcate that to a whole
generation of young people then their
entire identity is then invested in that
particular worldview and so to challenge
that becomes more than just kind of
having an open honest conversation it
becomes about essentially challenging
how they perceive themselves and I think
that that seems to make people really
uncomfortable at a fundamental level and
that's why I think that it's really
important now to try and really unpack
these essentially fact free stories new
that are being perpetuated or we're
gonna have a whole group of people that
define their entire identity by this
kind of victim grievance narrative and
and internalize that and then again it
becomes a self-fulfilling prophecy
because people start to have a chip on
their shoulder people start to perceive
the world around them differently and
again it's really instant because I know
this from experience I grew up in a
relatively conservative household but
for a very short period of time I was
really interested in these work ideas
and I started spending a lot of time
with people that perpetuated them and I
saw how it actually changed me and that
was really interesting I think that's
one of the reasons why I think I'm quite
passionate about it is that you know I
started to see you know in normal
interactions with people as perhaps and
prejudicial or like that people were you
know judging me based off of my race and
their society itself was structured
against me and that almost there was
nothing that they can I could do about
it and this is some of the things that
are being told and people do believe and
I think that that massively changes what
you believe is possible for yourself so
I think that we have two separate
peoples as I said before subjective
judgments with what the facts of the
matter is and that's why I'm so adamant
about telling the truth about what the
situation is so some of the things that
have been said is you know all these
different aspects of society this notion
of systemic racism but when you actually
unpack many of these concepts and the
different layers of society the picture
is much more complex so let's take for
example education the situation for
British Nigerian children is almost
completely different to the situation
for British Jamaican George oh yeah you
guys are smashing it I used to be a
teacher West African goes are one of the
highest achieving subgroups in all of
education yeah exactly and you know yeah
exactly higher than the average in the
in the country hmm but the situation is
different for British Caribbean boys so
why is that that can't be solely down to
systemic racism because we have
disparities quite significant
disparities amongst ethnic groups and
BMI ethnic groups themselves and
similarly you know with British Indian
people and British Chinese and people
have actually has a higher average
earning than the white British
population that's gonna make for a great
you're getting canceled this is just it
kind of just proves them that there is
so much more to the conversation and so
people are jumping on this simplistic
narrative and what it's doing is you
know having these very blanket
one-size-fits-all solutions which are
ultimately counterproductive and so what
I'm really interested in is what is not
being talked about in this conversation
you know we all talk about racism and
all of these times the things
but very few people are talking about
notions of agency culture personal
responsibility and class and I think
these are quite a complex assortment of
factors that are massively if not
predominantly shaping social outcomes in
this country don't you think part of the
problem is that people go oh you know
black people when the reality is you
know African and Caribbean are
completely different they're different
culturally different in the way they see
the world they'd have different values
and it's not just that you know Africa
is a very large continent so somebody
who is from Mali is going to be
essentially very very different to
someone who is Moroccan yeah so I think
that there are kind of differences
within black groups is ivory I think is
a really interesting one so for example
particularly people from West Africa
most of them are not actually
descendants from slaves means I'm what I
think that's quite a big distinction
between the Caribbean community and I
think some of the legacies in terms of
even internalized racism and different
issues relate to that that also and play
a part in the kind of relationship
between how they you know perceive
themselves and you know their
relationship with Britain and for
example Caribbean predominantly it came
to Britain decades before many of the
kind of Ghanaian and Nigerian migrants
there are still some very strong kind of
rooted values in terms of conservatism
that permeate many people of African
heritage in Britain so I think that
these kinds of these kinds of things are
shaping the the relationship between
race and kind of social outcomes in this
country are massively being being missed
so in some ways and I don't want to put
these words in your mouth but I'm just
curious to explore this let's say a
first generation Ghanaian might have
more in common with the first generation
Russian immigrant then they might do
with a British born Caribbean person is
that kind of yeah no exactly I do think
that that is the case and so that's why
I think there's kind of blanket systemic
racism institutional racism argument is
missing these kinds of nuances and
complexities of the situation and on top
of that what's really interesting you
know I kind of touched on this notion of
agency and personal responsibility
something that I would really like to
explore further again it's quite a
sensitive topic but there's a culture
within particularly some communities
predominantly black communities of this
whole notion of like you're acting white
and I actually think that some of
actually seems to me is have some
connections with this whole Uncle Tom
culture that we're seeing you know you
know you you're you're a [ __ ] all these
kinds of things you know just define a
few of those things for people who may
be less familiar like we're obviously
all very versed in this stuff but first
of all what does it mean to be acting
white and then talk to us about the
whole Uncle Tom phenomenon yeah so I
think it's you know I think it seems to
happen less when other people leave
school but I think it's something that
I've seen a lot among school kids you
know black kids that might be
nonconformist or interested in
traditionally white type of things that
people say maybe rock music despite the
fact that that has often origins as well
in like Jimi Hendrix and things like
that but things like that and a lot of
young kids have said oh you're you're
acting why and and I think that that can
actually shape the perception of what
black culture is to young people and I
think that when they think of what it
means to be black in Britain contributed
by the community itself is often a very
narrow perception of what blackness
actually is and I think that these types
of things also have a massive
contributing factor into the way
blackness is then represented in the
wider society and I think that that's
really something that has nothing
necessarily to do with white people or
whiteness and that's why I think this
conversation needs to be much more
internal and reflective in regards to
what are we doing as individuals within
our own community so to speak to you
perpetuate certain ideas and beliefs and
behaviors that could be limiting the way
that we perceive our potential so yeah
and then talk to us about the whole one
called Tom sing as well yeah I think
particularly in the last few months this
has been something that I've seen grow
at an really exponential rate you know
we've seen it we've kind of Priti Patel
issue soon AK or even other ethnic
minority people that have become really
successful do not perceive themselves or
as oppressed or victimized back
knowledge racism exist but don't feel
that they are defined by F or claim to
be somehow agents of white supremacy
or agents of perpetuating you know a
racist system and again I think is it's
such a limiting perception of what it
means to be any of these different
groups because from my understanding at
least integration or at least progress
to me would be seeing intellectual
diversity ideological diversity amongst
all of these different people that
they're no longer solely a political
based off of their race alone that their
political interests are defined by so
much more than that
and so what I'm finding now the
strongest perpetuators of these kind of
very rigid stereotypes is limiting
stereotypes is not coming from the kind
of traditional far-right um kind of
white racist it's coming from this
section of the work left in particular
they have a very narrow perception of of
ethnic minorities and it's not just in
our perception it's an actual denial of
you know a lot of these ethnic
minorities are socially conservative
because they're first-generation
immigrants no it's really interesting
and you know I hope that going forward
as we have more of these conversations
more and more people will see that
actually you know the left isn't
necessarily the natural home now I don't
actually identify as necessarily on the
left or the right but I do think a lot
of the conservative values that many
immigrant communities do you grow up in
do you seem to find a stronger place in
kind of conservatism more broadly and I
really hope that as this kind of
conversation progresses we can see far
more intellectual and ideological
diversity and political experimentation
amongst them ethnic minority community
alright well that concludes about twenty
minutes section of the into where I
massively derailed you from talking
about the free speech Union and what's
happening now and let's go back to that
cuz I do think it's important the
question I asked you at the very
beginning was do you think things have
got better with free speech or said
they've got worse in the last few weeks
with everything that's been going on I
think that is massively got worse and I
don't say that lightly and not only do I
you know think it's got worse I think
it's incredibly dangerous the place that
we're in we are talking about particular
from the black lives matter narrative in
particular asking they're calling for
quite significant transformational
changes of our society and none of this
can pretend
none of this can possibly happen in a
positive way if we are not embedded in
an existing social climate which people
where people feel able to come forward
to challenge to to engage in
constructive discourse and and tell the
truth about what they feel you know
people I'm seeing a feeling compelled to
lie many people have emailed me and come
to me telling me you know their friends
are gonna leave them if they don't put a
black square or say black lives matter
none of these things are conducive to a
constructive and positive forward facing
vision you know I want people to tell
the truth I want people to tell me when
I'm wrong and actually free speech right
now is massively in decline and and not
just from a kind of you know traditional
conception of free speech in relation to
conversation but but even that the way
in which we are conceiving of our own
history we are seeing this kind of very
one-dimensional overly negative
characterization of Britain and British
history which is then shaping again what
I said before this the way in which
people are deceiving themselves and I
think that freedom of speech as I said
is just so important in regards to
obviously the pursuit of higher meaning
and truth you know that the basis of
free speech is also this whole idea of
obviously as in a democracy we all have
equal power and shape to be able to
shape our society and you know free
speech is that the mechanism to which we
can really understand each other and if
we don't really start to defend it and
protecting in a meaningful way
I think that we are we're in kind of
really dangerous territory it's
interesting you say you know we're in
dangerous territory because thank the
Lord that I'm not involved in a
corporate environment anymore but I can
imagine especially you know with the you
know the black lives matter movement if
you have any sort of qualms about this
particular movement or the notion of
white privilege you dare not say allowed
in a corporate environment well I find
really interesting and I've written
about this and slightly is the way in
which corporations have been so
accepting of the black lives matter
narrative and I think a lot of people
with impact lies massive thing that
they're really radical and think that
they're kind of challenging power
structures but actually that the kind of
the way in which corporations have been
so part and parcel of this process to me
is a really interesting development in
regards to how corporations and
the powers that be the kind of political
cultural and media establishment don't
actually see black lives matter as a
threat and I think that that's because
many of the them things that are being
pushed forward by black lives matter are
actually incredibly divisive you know it
is very much this divide and rule game
that I would argue am undermined
solidarity amongst working-class people
across races and so people were kind of
fighting amongst themselves instead of
seeing the kind of broader question
about the way in which the structures
within our society are increasing social
injustice and extreme economic
inequality in equality for all people
not just black people and so it suits
and the corporate kind of ideology very
well but not just because of that well
also because it means that they can
engage in very superficial gestures of
you know putting a black square saying
down to white supremacy all of these
types of things but the genuinely
meaningful horrific wrongs that are
going on in the present day perpetuated
by many of the kind of corporate
interests get ignored by just so that so
instead they can just put these kind of
very simplistic superficial gestures and
you know they get their way quick points
for that and so I think that I find it
very interesting that that woke miss as
an ideology it seemed very comfortable
within the corporate realm and I think
that that tells us very much about you
know if it's really challenging anything
meaningful in other words a big company
can you know put the black square give
some money to black lives matter while
employing people paying the minimum wage
in horrible conditions of all colors
because they're too busy you know
engaged in this protest or in this
movement as opposed to campaigning for
their right to actually be paid better
or to have better working conditions
exactly I mean elites are fascinating
examples it's just ridiculous so you
know you had pep guardiola the
manchester city manager coming out and
talked about slavery well it's being
bankrolled by Abu Dhabi and you just
think I mean is this and no one brings
it up well you know this whole thing
about slavery you know I think it's
again another really worrying trend
everybody in the society I think there's
almost you name it singing about you
know the slavery and the things that
went on in the past were horrific wrongs
really defends that but we cannot be
bound by our history you know the human
story is complex is multifaceted it's
the story of triumph conquest pain and
courage and that's you know a traumatic
one but also a beautiful one at some
point we've got to be able to recognize
that we have to take responsibility for
our lives in the present day and I'm
also worried about this really
one-dimensional narrative about slavery
against slavery was and is a completely
horrific thing but also for example
working-class white people in Britain
have suffered indentured servitude and
horrific conditions and so black people
don't have a monopoly on oppression they
don't have a monopoly on suffering and I
think that again framing just the black
identity solely based over these really
negative characteristics will only way
people down and I think there isn't just
one idea of as I said what blackness is
what progress looks like how do we get
there we've got to really platform the
vast range of intellectual and
ideological diversity that exists
amongst the black population but start
focusing on the positive focusing on the
future because you know people can't be
weighed down by these horrific things
that happened in history and I was gonna
say you know you talk about the
importance of being able to have this
free conversation but we've seen and I
know that this is something the free
speech Union cares about and is working
on we've seen people who've you know I
saw the transcript initially you know
when you see these news reports they
never tell you what actually happened
have you noticed this lately like when
they talk about a case where somebody
said something they weren't supposed to
say and then they got fired they never
actually give you the information about
what that person said you know someone
gets to remove from Twitter you never
find out why right because when you do
this guilin is the Isle of Wight
this presenter yes the radio presenter
absolute right so he had what seemed
like a pretty reasonable conversation to
me with a black caller and he he said to
the caller actually I'm not you know I
haven't had any more privileged than you
and that was his opinion now he might be
right he might be wrong I don't know how
privilege has been I don't anything
about him but he was instantly removed
pending in the subject of an
investigation this whole thing so how do
we have these conversations if
you question it in your case you become
an Uncle Tom or in are in the case of a
white person who's employed they get
fired how do how do I would talk about
it I think that we've really got to
expose this bidding in a well for you
completely for days there is they talk a
lot about compassion and empathy but
actually there is completely nothing and
pathetic or compassionate about assuming
that particular state listening to
particular statements and then defining
an entire person's worldview or belief
based over those few statements or just
blanketing an entire group of people
there's nothing compassionate about that
I've heard stories of example friends
that tell me that they've you know
they've got racist grandparents or yeah
and I find that really interesting you
know my instinct is not to go all these
people that really evil people I'm
really interested in you know what why
people have these kinds of what views
what what makes them think that and I
think only one we can do that can we
meaningfully address those things but
some of those things are not even you
know necessarily motivated by hatred or
for a group of people some people have
genuinely never come across you know a
black person that they've been in a very
insular small community their entire
life and there's various stereotypes
that permeate within that community and
you know so so there's many different
reasons for why people come to the
different conclusions that they've come
to about the world and that's what we
need to seek to understand I think we
really have to expose this particular
worldview for what it is I think it's
really interesting even the whole
definition of racism that they propagate
they frame the definition of racism in a
way for them to never be able to be
raised
it's like and even what we were talking
about earlier about history you know
that if you are solely defined by your
history then how can you ever be
responsible for your own actions and so
the way that they frame the situation is
for they can never do wrong they can
never say anything wrong or be
responsible and that gives them a green
light to be able to do anything they
want without any consequences and that's
not compassionate that's not creating a
better world to create a better world we
have to go far beyond now we have to
reach across tribal lines and and and
try and genuinely understand each other
and create solutions but on top of that
I I oppose this whole idea of white
privilege you know again I understand
why
people kind of say it they argue that
for example white people if they're
going to be oppressed by anything it's
not going to be because of their race
but again I think that these kinds of
really simplistic narratives are really
divisive so one thing is I think that we
are all privileged and disadvantaged for
a whole rate a whole host of reasons you
know there's people that grow up poor
but they have you know a really strong
community and family
you know there's people that are rich
and you know don't have that there are
many different things that make us who
we are and that's genuinely
compassionate that's genuinely empathy
in common humanity and on top of that
there are many white people that I've
come across and spoken to you that have
contacted me who genuinely don't feel
privileged because of their white
because that of their race you know
whether that is the fact that white
working-class always have the lowest
educational attainment in this country
there's been whole scandals to do of
grooming gangs which is a whole another
issue in itself the idea that the only
form of the only valid form of grievance
is a racial one and that should be the
only kind of way in which we can engage
in this conversation about privilege is
just frankly not true and do you think
part of the problem is that the people
who are talking about things about white
privilege tend to be white middle-class
and white upper-class people oh this is
you know I think this is a really
interesting point because you know
especially with this whole conversation
about Meghan Michael for example there
was this whole I uh you know argument
that she was kind of a victim of racism
and a lot of the time it's framed as
kind of poor white working-class people
that have all of these bigoted attitudes
but from my experience and what I've
seen the working-class in Britain
actually the most diverse group many
most of the information relationships
and you know mixed-race children and all
of these things are actually happening
amongst working-class people who have
also been at the forefront of most
anti-racist struggles in Britain for the
last few decades so this whole framing
and about you know you know dividing it
by race and class in this way it's just
doesn't stack up to reality and what I
found is that it's often you know the
middle-class white middle-class
narrative I don't want to again frame it
solely by race but I just think it's
interesting that a seems to be wanting
to be the kind of savior and the answer
to all of these issues and a ways to
kind of look down on a valid way of
prejudice on a group of people which is
kind of the white working class
population I find that very interesting
so I think that again the many of the
narratives when we actually investigate
them don't actually stack up to this
very binary oppressor versus oppressed
narratives that we are being told well
I'm listening to you and it makes
perfect sense to me and as you know I
agree with with much of what you say but
I saw a CNN poll I think and people some
people who've done like CNN are gonna
you know be upset about that but I
suspect it's probably quite accurate
which shows that somewhere between 60
and 70 percent of black people in this
country do feel that the police treat
them worse because they're black do feel
discriminated against do you think their
systemic racism so you know either
either you're wrong or that what you're
talking about is correct but it's not
cutting through to ordinary people how
do you explain that yeah I think that
again so people feeling that way whether
we like it or not doesn't necessarily
mean it's true we've got to be confident
and I you know feel comfortable to be
able to challenge people's feelings
because our feelings change and our
feelings and can be wrong and even many
of the things about the kind of systemic
racism in police brutality again I
believed in the past until I actually
looked into it so I think that a lot of
a lot of people haven't been confident
to actually challenge what the facts are
for example though the BBC itself
reported that in that a lot of people
are talking about you know deaths in
police custody in the last 10 years 163
people have died in police custody in 10
years 13 were black so that's you know
about one a year and actually by the
BBC's own statistics a white person was
25% more likely to die in police custody
than a black person so people are taking
one figure one statistic and and not
actually showing the whole picture so if
we only talk about this one statistic
without showing the entire context then
of course we're going to assume that
people are being treated differently I
mean another example is that you know
ethnic minority or black people are more
likely to be in poverty and this that
the other well the chief of the matter
is I think something like 1/3 of black
ethnic minority in this country are
foreign-born so many of them come from
poor country
so you're gonna come from a poor country
and obviously oftentimes you do start at
the bottom that doesn't mean that you're
being discriminated against or systemic
racism it just means that it takes time
to move up the social ladder and those
opportunities are there and so again we
talk about ethnic minorities in relation
to crime
well again being coming from a immigrant
household you're more likely to be in an
impoverished community and there's many
different things that affect in terms of
impoverishment crime that relate to that
so that's not a lot of these things can
actually just be explained and
unresolved and don't necessarily have
anything in relation to an institutional
or systemic racism and I think about
always about my own upbringing so I grew
up in an area of South London which had
real problems with race that Bob Dam I
wrote is a BMP public had an England why
do you keep saying up at the England
flag you said that every time and then
although all of you having an impact
doesn't make you know I know it doesn't
it doesn't absolutely doesn't make you
racist and any free shape or form
however the pub was a being people in it
and that's where they used to me up and
you know and there was assaults against
Asian people and all the rest of it and
it feels like we've made huge progress
have we taken a step back as a result of
what's been happening at the moment so I
think it's a really important point that
you mentioned the BNP pop because again
when I was saying in the beginning about
race relations being perhaps one of the
one things that we can try of it but the
BNP has literally collapsed as a
political movement
I think Britain is one of the only
countries in the West who do not have a
far-right force as a coherent you know
political force that is saying something
and so I think that we are taking a
regressive step and you know it does pay
me to say that because as I said before
to tell a whole generation of young
people that are living in such a yeah
there's definitely things more to be
done and I'm not going to deny that but
I personally think most of them all that
needs to be done is relating to
individual mentality agency and personal
responsibility that's my opinion but
there is obviously more to be done but
then saying this completely permeating
this almost every single day is such a
divisive situation I've seen friendship
groups that have been friends for
decades
all of a sudden you know defining their
friendship group on racial lines you
know one friend saying or what can I do
to help you as a black person and it was
never like that before they never talked
about race in such a divisive way but
this whole narrative and being permeated
of naturally becomes internalized as is
embedded in our own culture so I think
it is a regressive step I think going
forward I hope that we are moving
towards more of a colorblind society
where people but that's racist now but
that's literally what people say no idea
of a colorblind society is racist I keep
getting people telling me that that's
not what Martin Luther King meant when
he said people should be judged on the
content of their character he didn't
mean a colorblind society he was a
revolutionary he want to tow us Road the
white patriarchy or whatever it is is
that not true no I don't think that's
true and you know the alternative of a
colorblind society would mean to
sacrifice the whole idea of meritocracy
you know we see this with them hiring
practices it seems it's more likely now
that you will be hired to feel a tick
box in a quota not necessarily by a you
know normal kind of competition to get a
job and so that completely undermines
the idea of meritocracy and and that
again creates a self-fulfilling prophecy
like black kids think they're getting a
job because of their race and that you
know and and that they didn't need to
think about that before and so I think
that a colorblind society if not what we
have now should absolutely be the goal I
would even like to see again this is a
you know probably a more out-there idea
but we talk about anti racism what I'd
really like to see is us even thinking
far more imaginatively and bigger in
terms of could we even overcome race is
that something even possible I think
that if we are serious about you know
transforming our society to make it
fairer and more just and you know freer
I think that we've really got to go
beyond these artificial character
categories and start being far more
imaginative in relation to how we relate
to each other and so go for it no okay
so what would you what would you
implement if you this is the core this
is a real question like you talked about
agency instability of like what do you
think people need to do and we as a
society need to do
as well to to to overcome those yeah so
there's a few things and obviously
there's top-down top-level things I'm
bottom level things from the top level
thing I think that the you know we need
to stop continually perpetuating this
idea that Britain is this society I
think we need to be completely confident
in saying that we are not this society
you know it's imperfect but we are a
positive forward tolerant country and
but there is absolutely more that we can
do and we stand united all as British
people whether wherever it come from but
we are all here together as British
people so from the top level I'd love to
see far more kind of moral and political
leadership in not being so cowardly in
the face of these movements and I think
that that would be really really strong
she's talking about Boris Johnson that's
part of the problem many of these people
think they can get away with it because
there's no push button and so there's
got to be something on the top level but
from the bottom up I think that we
absolutely need to cultivate a far more
culture of criticism you know critique
is now considered hate or criticism you
know you kind of ensure a platform as
someone that thinks differently to you I
don't think they're that successful I
think that we need to cultivate a
culture of criticism where debate and
discussion and these difficult ideas
become embedded into our daily lives I
think that that would really I think
raise the level of consciousness
political consciousness but also help
people's recognize that you know you
don't necessarily have moral superiority
you know there are reasons why we all
think differently and we all can
contribute in this open environment to
be able to create solutions together and
negotiate change so that from the bottom
up I would love to see that far more in
schools far more critical and deep
intellectual engagement to embed that
kind of culture of tolerance and mutual
understanding and deep kind of rigorous
intellectual debate in order to foster
genuine meaningful intellectual
diversity not just kind of diversity of
colour what about on the individual
level you talk about agency
responsibility these are all words that
don't mean much to many people did
they're just you know so what are you
talking about so I think that I'm really
interested in if we all as individuals
cultivated
as much as we can as a sense that we
could actually achieve and did
everything that we as individuals first
could do to make our lives better I
think that that that would completely
transform our society I think that well
we there is an automatic response to
assume and blame external factors and
sometimes obviously there are external
factors that play a part
but as I've seen with my own life and my
own family who in many ways came from
nothing in Britain and were able to
transform their life there is clearly a
potential within all of us to be able to
do something different to be able to
shape our future and shape our reality
and I think that that that's that kind
of deep reflective and internal work
exposing ourselves to different ideas
seeing how we feel and respond to these
different ideas you know get creating a
more coherent and refined argument and
that's ultimately you know how you
develop a sense of personal independence
and personal freedom you know we live in
a culture that's very that uses the word
safety a lot no you here but on campus a
safe space it needs to be safe for
students that we need risk we need to be
braver we need to be more courageous
these are the types of values I think we
should be prioritizing and and kind of
elevating in our society not safety not
risk aversion not kind of limiting our
surroundings to our echo-chamber I think
that's how we really start to create an
environment where we think outside the
box
innovate and and kind of move beyond
these very limiting constraints and so
you've graduated University not not long
ago and you've touched on the campus and
university culture a lot how much
responsibility do you universities need
to take for the current climate that we
find ourselves in I think a huge
responsibility I think for a long time
people thought that you know it was just
these friend students being kind of a
bit zealot being zealots and it didn't
really mean anything or fade out but
actually that's not what's happened
we've seen it with the New York Times
for example the I think is the opinion
editor has been forced to resign for
platforming and Republican defending
Donald Trump because all of these new
liberal woke young people are kind of
forcing the the magazine to completely
change its culture so what has happened
is these students that and academics
obviously have now obviously moved into
everyday life and in our
forming the institutions we've seen it
with you know this whole situation with
JK rowling so I think that the academics
and that kind of limiting academic
climber which is in many ways the brain
of our society universities that
naturally then permeates as the educated
class then become the elite the cultural
and media elite and so I think that that
has a really big part to play and I hope
that you know going forward universities
wake up I think now we've covered 19
that they're facing a really huge
funding gap in a funding vacuum so I
think that this is the climate now for
us to actually make some significant
changes but it can go either way I
really think so I know it's been great
chatting with you thank you so much for
coming on the show we have just one more
question for you and it's the one we
always finish with which is what is the
one thing we're not talking about as a
society that we really should be and so
I guess I've touched upon it a little
bit already I think it is personal
responsibility I think that we are very
quick to blame external factors for our
situation and absolutely there is a role
to play for that but I would really love
to see far more people taking
responsibility for their lives shaping
themselves as individuals and seeing how
far they can go within that their selves
as an individual then within their
families and communities and going
beyond that not just automatically going
for shaping society at large she's
saying clean your room the other person
in the eye and have some bloody backbone
I think that's it isn't it like it's
about recognizing that of course
external factors can and will affect
your life and it's inevitable and we all
get ill and all kinds of things will
happen but if you take responsibility
for your part you'll find that 90% of
the things you're unhappy with can be
resolved that you're on work right
exactly
hmm well it's great to have someone like
you very young and spreading that
message to people we really appreciate
coming on the show and our view as well
as well so thanks very much where can
people follow you and your work and what
can people do to support the free speech
union as well yeah just sign up to free
speech union to all but you can follow
me on Twitter and I have flarin or my
website and I Florian comm Thanks
and thanks to tune in guys we'll see you
very soon with another interview or a
live stream make sure if you haven't
checked out one of the lines trees
they're very funny especially when I'm
on yeah absolutely we will see you soon
guys take care and thank you very much
for watching or listening thanks for
watching guys as always subscribe to the
YouTube channel click the bell button
next to subscribe button so you get
notified when a video comes out and
follow us on all the social media at
trigger pot and also leave us a nice
review on iTunes and spread the word